without the TVA all of this everything
is gone this is what Loki told Sylvie
near the end of Loki season 2 episode 2
and this tells us a lot about where
Loki's head is at he also says this if
what he who remains said is true the TVA
is the only defense this is big because
we can clearly see here that Loki agrees
that the TVA should exist and it is in
fact an entity for good not bad he
believes what he who remains said is
true and I actually think that after all
of this is said and done Loki season 2
Deadpool 3 Avengers Secret Wars when all
of it is said and done Loki could
actually become he who remains no I am
not saying he is a variant of King but
he who remains can be considered a title
the last person at the end of time and I
think Loki is realizing throughout the
course of Loki season 2 too that there
does have to be somebody there
monitoring everything to make sure the
Multiverse doesn't get destroyed and I
think he's going to take that upon
himself and possibly Sylvie as well now
this decision is what Loki and Sylvie
are going to be fighting about
throughout the course of Loki season 2
clearly Loki thinks that the TVA is good
and Sylvie thinks that the TVA is bad
both of them want free will for the
entire Multiverse however Loki
understands that Free Will comes with a
cost and this is basically what he who
remains was saying he who remains
essentially gave Loki and Sylvia the
choice to become him and as Loki stated
several times in season 2 episode 1 he
just wanted time to think in that moment
which is why he tried to stop Sylvie
from killing him because his biggest
concern was what if he's right what if
he who remains was indeed telling the
truth and that if they killed him bigger
bad people would come and essentially
the entire Multiverse the reality that
he knows and everyone knows will be
destroyed and that will be the end
essentially of existence this is further
backed up by a scene that we've seen in
trailers but not in the episodes yet and
the scene is where we hear Sylvie tell
Loki we're playing God and that's when
Loki says we are Gods I mentioned this
in a previous video but this could
actually be Loki's glorious purpose both
Loki and Sylvie because Sylvie is a Loki
could their glorious purpose be to rule
the TVA I think this is going to play
out not only over Loki season 2 but also
throughout the course of Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars because I do
believe Loki thinks that the TVA is a
good and necessary thing and needs to
continue in order to preserve the
Multiverse however we do also basically
know that in Avengers King Dynasty The
Avengers are going to lose and the
Multiverse is indeed going to collapse
in fact we know that's going to happen
before in Deadpool 3 and we know that
the TVA is going to play a big part in
Deadpool 3 and probably Loki now I'm
sure Loki trusts Mobius to do the right
thing and handle the TVA but we don't
know what Mobius ending is going to be
in Loki season 2 perhaps he goes
somewhere on a timeline and gets his jet
ski finally plus there's always the fact
that Mobius might not want to be the
person in charge of the TVA and would
probably think that Loki is the most
fitted after all he is a God and at this
point in time and by the end of Loki
season 2 he will have had the most
knowledge about he who remains and what
he has done and we assume he's going to
to interact with at least a few
different variants of he who remains
throughout Loki season 2 so he'll have
somewhat the knowledge that he who
remains had to basically be able to run
the TVA and the question that many fans
are asking right now is Will Loki
actually want to do this and I believe
Yes again I think that he might think
it's his glorious purpose this isn't
just trying to take over New York or
Earth for bad reasons or as he says in
episode 2 because he was actually mad at
his brother and father love that level
of vulnerability but this is a
completely different cause this is for
good this is Loki becoming the hero
stepping away from the Arc of the
villain this would be the ultimate
character development from Loki being a
villain in the first Thor movie wanting
to rule over Asgard to wanting to take
over New York and Earth to wanting to
rule the TVA for villainous reasons and
now wanting to rule the TVA to actually
save everybody in the Multiverse it's
incredible growth and something I would
love to see however there is is going to
be one thing I believe that stands in
the way of him doing this and that is
Sylvie and the reason that she is
actually going to stand in the way of
Loki instead of him just brushing her
off and stating well agree to disagree
is because he loves her we haven't seen
it on screen yet but executive producer
Kevin Wright has stated that they are
going to explore even further the
relationship between Sylvie and Loki
romantically so why would she stop him
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
first big thank you to fume for
sponsoring this video fume is a
GameChanger for a lot of people in
turning bad habits into good habits a
lot of people struggle with these bad
habits but fume looks at these in a
different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're awardwinning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the B bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's
trf m.com and use code Cosmic to save an
additional 10% off your order today
Sylvia is going to be the biggest
problem for Loki because right now Loki
is severely suffering from heartache and
Sylvia of course caused that and you can
really tell by Tom heston's amazing
acting in Loki episode 2 he's messed up
but he knows that the Multiverse is at
stake right now but Sylvie doesn't care
about the TVA and she even states that
if she sees another variant of he who
remains she's just going to kill him
Loki even stated so what you just give
people Free Will and then bounce and she
said yeah you're welcome but we know
that Sylvia is going to come back and we
know that Victor timley is going to come
into the picture and Sylvia is most
likely going to try to kill him we also
know that Rin Slayer is going to be
coming back as well her and miss minutes
are going to be two of the villains of
the show and that's really not going to
help Sylvie think the TVA is good
because they're probably going to try to
take over the TVA themselves and her
very last words to Loki in the end of
episode 2 was the TVA is broken and it's
rotten but here's the thing Loki
understands that it's broken broken and
he wants to fix it in a way that can
give people free will but also keeps
away the boogeyman he who remains King
the Conqueror Etc he believes that he
can do this as the ruler of the TVA but
sylv is going to have a problem with
this because she did at the end of the
first season where she said I'm a fool I
should have known all along you just
wanted to be in charge of the TVA you
wanted the power the control so Sylvie
might get in the way of Loki in which
we're probably going to have a battle
between the two of them but she could
also come around because Loki could make
some pretty compelling arguments plus if
Sylvie is involved in the control of the
TVA she could also make sure herself
that people's Free Will does actually
exist and is given to them but at the
same time she can kill all the evil Kang
variants she wants it's kind of a
win-win for Sylvie so if they both
agreed that the TVA was the only way to
keep people safe the two of them could
rule it together essentially becoming he
who remains like he said was kind of the
only option before there were only two
options they take his place literally as
he who remains as the last two people at
the end of time riding time for people
or his evil variants come and destroy
the Multiverse there were only two
options and perhaps that remains true
today here's the only thing though like
I said we know that the Multiverse is
basically going to collapse and we've
been hearing about a MCU soft reboot so
what happens then well again in Deadpool
3 we've heard that TVA is going to start
to gather a bunch of different heroes
from a bunch of different universes and
put them all in one Universe from what
we know they're doing this to save the
heroes save the heroes so that they can
actually fight for the Multiverse and an
attempt to save it and hopefully after
restore it the problem is though we've
seen a lot of the TVA and we've never
seen them restore any timeline or
universe so we're more than likely going
to move forward in the MCU after Secret
Wars in a completely new universe where
the Multiverse still does exist so the
TVA will still be necessary and
somebody's going to have to run it and
the further we go into Loki season 2 the
more I believe that this truly is Loki
and possibly sylv's glorious purpose but
let us know what you think about this in
the comments down below do you think
Loki becomes he who remains and if so do
you think Sylvie will join him let us
know your thoughts don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the Loki theories and
of course the latest MCU news also if
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win a PS5
an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items where some DC items as well the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
woof